Dude! What the f*ck are you doing?
I had to go to the bathroom.
While I’m in the tub?
Well, it was an emergency.
That's not even cool, man. Especially when
we have a whole other bathroom downstairs.
I didn’t think I could make it to the other
one.
It’s 20 paces away!
Well that would have been at least 16 paces
too many, trust me, and then you’d be mad
at me for making a mess on the floor, alright?
So, what do you want me to do?
Are you sure you want to do this? I mean…
there’s a camera right there.
Why are you filming yourself taking a bath?
I don't think that's any of your business
actually.
I think maybe it is. Can you at least cover
up?
What?!
Like, cover up, dude. Like, your Johnson right
in my field of view and I'm trying to do stuff.
My Johnson is identical to your Johnson, dude.
I'm not entirely sure why you would care that
it was in your line of view.
I don’t want people thinking we’re gay
or something.
You say that kind of thing a lot. I’m starting
to think maybe you're a homophobe.
No, I'm not a homophobe, you're a homophobe,
homophobe. You freaking homophobe.
I am not a homophobe.
Yep.
I’m just… straight. I mean, I'm sure if
the right situation presented itself, you
know, with the right person, you know, I would
go gay.
You would go gay? Who would you go gay for?
Probably like a movie star or a movie character,
right?
Who in the movies, if you were given a chance,
would you go gay--
Denzel Washington.
You said that kind of fast.
No I didn’t. No I didn't.
Almost as if you’d thought about it before.
I've certainly never thought about going gay
for Denzel Washington.
Are you sure?
Or George Clooney.
Dude.
What about you, homophobe?
Dude, I'm not a homophobe.
Who would you go gay for in the movies.
Man, I don’t know. I’m like, really f*cking
straight. Like, really straight. It’d have
to be somebody like... Gandalf probably.
Liam Neeson?
No, no, no. Much more incredible than Liam
Neeson.
Mr. Incredible?
No, dude, if I'm gonna go gay for a movie
character, it's not gonna be a f*cking cartoon.
It's gonna be somebody magical and powerful,
like Gandalf.
I think I would go gay for Gandalf.
What?
Yeah. I mean, he’s wise. He’s funny. He’s
got super powers. I mean, what's not to like?
He’s like a thousand years old, though.
Dude, age ain’t nothing but a number, man.
Besides, that guy travels by eagle, man.
Only when the story calls for it.
I know who I would go gay for. From Life of
Pi. Richard Parker.
The tiger?
Yeah.
Man, he’d tear your face off.
Richard Pah-Kah!
(flush noise) Alright that's it. I’m coming
in.
There's not even enough room for the two of
us.
You should have thought of that before. Now
I’m naked now.
You didn't even wipe.
No! Richard Parker! No!